COMMITTEE.
NEXT STOP, A FULL SENATE
CONFIRMATION VOTE AS EARLY AS
TOMORROW.
BRET?
>> Bret: PETER DOOCY, LIVE ON
THE HILL.
LET'S GET MORE NOW FROM OKLAHOMA
SENATOR JAMES LANKFORD WHO SITS
ON THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IN
THE SENATE.
SENATOR, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
YOU ARE ASSESSMENT OF THIS
REPORT THAT CAME OUT OF YOUR
COMMITTEE TODAY, I HAD LOT OF
RIGHT UP SAYING, IT GOES REALLY
AGAINST THE HOUSE COMMITTEE ON
THIS VERY TOPIC.
>> Senator Lankford: IT'S AN
INTERESTING SPIN TO SAY IT GOES
AGAINST THE HOUSE COMMITTEE.
ALL WE DID WAS LOOK AT THE
ASSESSMENT FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THAT THEY DID IN
DECEMBER, LITERALLY THE FINAL
MONTH FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE PUT OUT A QUICK RUN THROUGH
OF WHAT INTELLIGENCE THEY HAD AT
THAT POINT, WE LOOKED AT IT AND
EVALUATED WHAT THEY HAD AT THAT
POINT INSIDE A "YES," THAT'S
WHAT THEY HAD.
THEY EVALUATED IT AND SET FOR
THE RUSSIANS TRYING TO HELP
PRESIDENT TRUMP AT THE END?
YES.
THE BIGGER QUESTION WAS NOT OUT
THERE, WHERE THEY ALWAYS TRYING
TO HELP THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
NO.
THAT'S NOT IN THE REPORT.
THE RUSSIAN STARTED WORKING ON
CAMPAIGN ISSUES IN THE
UNITED STATES IN 2014, THEY
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THE CANDIDATES
AT THAT POINT.
THEY WERE DETERMINED TO FIND
SOME WAY TO MEDDLE IN THE
CAMPAIGN AND WORKED FOR MULTIPLE
CAMPAIGNS THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS.
SO THAT WAS THROUGH THE FINAL
MONTHS.
WERE THEY TRYING TO ENGAGE WITH
AND THE FINAL MONTHS?
SURE.
WERE THEY IN THERE THE WHOLE
CAMPAIGN, NO THEY WERE NOT.
>> Bret: HERE IS THUS IN A
MINORITY REPORT ABOUT THAT
TRUMP TOWER MEETING.
>> SENATE REPUBLICANS
INTERVIEWED ONLY 12 WITNESSES IN
TOTAL.
AN INFAMOUS KREMLIN CONNECTED
LAWYER WAS ALLOWED TO PROVIDE
ONLY WRITTEN ANSWERS.
OUR REPUBLICAN FRIENDS DECIDED
NOT TO EVEN INTERVIEW TWO OF THE
OTHER KEY PARTICIPANTS IN    IN
OTHER KEY PARTICIPANTS IN    INH
OTHER KEY PARTICIPANTS IN    INE
MEETING.
JARED KUSHNER, AND PAUL
MANAFORT.
TO CALL THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEES TRUMP RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION HALF-HEARTED IS
TOO GENEROUS.
>> Bret: YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Senator Lankford: THAT IS A
SAD DESIGNATION OF WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE SENATE JUDICIARY.
HE KNOWS FULL WELL THAT THE
SENATE JUDICIARY AND SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE HAS GONE
THROUGH THIS.
I KNOW DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SOMETHING OF THIS BUT THIS
IS A RABBIT HOLE FOR THEM.
THEY ARE CONSTANTLY TRYING TO
ACCUSE AND SAYING THERE MUST BE
SOMETHING HERE THAT WE CAN STIR
UP OR AT LEAST CREATE AN
ACCUSATION THAT HAS THE
APPEARANCE OF IT.
WE INTERVIEWED EVERYONE WITH
THAT WAS THERE AND WENT THROUGH
ALL THE DOCUMENTS.
EVERYONE'S STORY HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT AND THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION THAT WAS PART OF THAT
MEETING.
IT WAS A DECEPTIVE REACH OUT
FROM AN INDIVIDUAL THAT THEY HAD
CONNECTED TO DURING ONE OF THE
PAGEANTS.
IT WAS A MUSIC PERSONALITY THAT
THEY MET WITH AS A PERSONAL
FAVOR.
WHEN YOU GO THROUGH ALL THE
INTERVIEWS, IT'S OBVIOUS THERE'S
NOTHING THERE AND THERE IS NO
REASON EVEN FOR THEM TO GO
THROUGH IT.
MY FEAR IS THAT DEMOCRATS
CONTINUE TO MAKE SOMETHING OUT
OF NOTHING AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THE FACTS INCLUDING ALL THE
TESTIMONY TODAY, YOU WILL SEE
THERE WAS NOTHING TO THAT
MEETING.
>> Bret: WHERE DOES THIS GO
NEXT?
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE WAITING FOR THE
NEXT SHOE TO DROP WITH A BOB
MUELLER INVESTIGATION BUT WHERE
DOES THIS ALL GO NEXT?
>> Senator Lankford: THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE RELEASES
THE REPORT AND WE RELEASED THE
SECOND PART OF OUR REPORT IN THE
DAYS AHEAD.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET OUT OF THAT
AS WELL AND WE ARE WRAPPING UP
OUR REPORTS AND TRYING TO GET
THROUGH ALL THE FINAL DOCUMENTS.
OUR HOPE IS THAT THE MOLAR
INVESTIGATION IS ALSO DRAWING TO
A CLOSE TO BE ABLE TO FINISH OUT
THEIR INVESTIGATION.
MY FEAR IS IF YOU GO BACK TO
IRAN-CONTRA AND INVESTIGATIONS
DONE BY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL AND
PRESIDENT REAGAN, THAT WAS SIX
YEARS THEY DRUGGED THAT OUT.
WE WANT TO HAVE THEM DO THEIR
WORK, FINISH THEIR WORK AND BE
ABLE TO GET IT DONE.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE
CONCERN THAT RUSSIA IS GOING TO
DO IT AGAIN IN THE MIDTERMS OR
2020?
>> Senator Lankford: WE SHOULD
BE AWARE IN ALL LIKELIHOOD,
RUSSIA WILL TRY SOMETHING AGAIN.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES FACE EVERY SINGLE YEAR
AND WESTERN EUROPEAN COUNTRIES
FACE MULTIPLE TIMES.
I ASSUME IF THEY DO IT ONCE THEY
WILL WILL DO IT AGAIN.
IT WILL JUST NEED TO BE AWARE
THAT IF THEY SEE THINGS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, THAT'S NOT ALWAYS
AN AMERICAN TRYING TO PUT OUT
INFORMATION ON EITHER SIDE OF AN
ISSUE.
AMERICANS ARE FREQUENTLY SEEING
SOCIAL MEDIA AND ASSUMING IT'S A
FELLOW CITIZEN, AND IT'S NOT.
>> Bret: THERE OBVIOUSLY A LOT
OF DEMOCRATS AND SOME OTHERS
THAT SAY THEY ARE NOT HAPPY WITH
WHAT THEY SAW FROM
DONALD TRUMP JR. IN THE
COMMITTEE, AND AS THE TRANSCRIPT
OF THE INTERVIEWS ARE BEING
RELEASED, HERE IS
SENATOR BLUMENTHAL ON ALL OF
THAT AND WHAT HE'S GOING
FORWARD.
>> HE NEEDS TO COME BACK AND
TESTIFY IN PERSON UNDER OATH.
THERE IS A LOT THAT NEEDS TO BE
EXPLAINED, THE CONTRADICTIONS
ARE APPARENT ON THE RECORD, BUT
EVEN MORE SO WHEN I ATTENDED
THIS INTERVIEW.
I HAVE NO CONFIDENCE THAT HE HAS
THAT.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK HE NEEDS
TO COME BACK?
>> Senator Lankford: I DON'T
THINK HE NEEDS TO COME BACK.
HE'S APPEARED BEFORE THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, HE'S DONE
HOURS AND HOURS OF TESTIMONY AND
THAT HAS BEEN CONSISTENT.
THEY ARE JUST DIGGING AND HOPING
THEY CAN FIND SOMETHING OR LEAVE
AND INNUENDO, THAT MAYBE THERE
IS A SECRET QUESTION THEY CAN
ASK TO FIND SOMETHING.
THE HARD PART IS AFTER MONTHS
AND MONTHS OF THIS
INVESTIGATION, THEY ARE NOT
FINDING ANYTHING.
MAYBE I COULD BRING HIM BACK ONE
MORE TIME, I WILL.
BUT IT'S JUST NOT THERE.
>> Bret: RUDY GIULIANI HAS
SAID THAT MUELLER HAS TOLD HIM
THAT HE WILL ADHERE TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT GUIDANCE, AND
THERE WILL NOT BE AN INDICTMENT
OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> Senator Lankford: QUITE
FRANKLY, THAT'S THE SAME THING
THAT JIM COMEY TOLD THE
PRESIDENT.
HE TOLD THE PRESIDENT OUT THREE
TIMES IN THEIR MEETINGS.
EITHER THAT HAS COME UP, OR THEY
HAVE BOTH SAID THAT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
SO I WOULD BE SURPRISED BY THAT
BUT I DIDN'T HEAR IT FIRSTHAND
THAT THERE WASN'T GOING TO BE AN
INDICTMENT, BUT THAT WOULDN'T
SURPRISE ME AS THAT HASN'T BEEN
THE CENTER OF THE INVESTIGATION
NOR HAS THE ROLE OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO TRY TO GET AN
INDICTMENT BY THE PRESIDENT.
HIS ROLE WAS VERY CLEAR TO SEE
IF THERE WAS CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
AMONGST THE CAMPAIGN.
THE PRESIDENT HAS EVER BEEN
LISTED AS THE SOURCE OF THIS
ACTIVITY, OR THAT THESE
ACTIVITIES EVEN EXISTED.
HE WAS DOING RESEARCH TO SEE IF
ANYTHING DID OCCUR.
TO BE ONE LAST THING, HOW LONG
DO YOU THINK THIS IS GOING TO
TAKE BEFORE WE KNOW A CONCLUSION
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER?
>> Senator Lankford: THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS, THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE WILL WRAP
UP YOUR WORK AND GET THEIR
INFORMATION OUT THERE SO
EVERYONE CAN SEE IT AND AS MUCH
POSSIBLE DETAIL AS WE CAN GET
OUT IN CLASSIFIED FORM.
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
IS ALREADY WRAPPING UP AND WE
WOULD HOPE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
WILL DO THE SAME.
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T CONTROL
SPECIAL COUNSEL, WE ARE
INDEPENDENT OF US BUT WE HAVE
GONE THROUGH A LOT
GONE THROUGH A LOT OF INTERVIEWS